[Music]
then eat to extinct news
I'm gonna buy tech yeah well hungry
Chinese people offered to eat Denmark's
oyster problem to extinction there's not
boy stur froggy I want to go in an
oyster problem but that is so [ __ ]
Chinese dude I love bursting out of your
mouth that that want to go yeah I like
alia said I want I want to go help you
danish people yeah they're having me
unwanted in bail I just saw your finger
like right here we have oysters farms
out here because we wanted so bad yeah
they're just China why don't they just
sell the [ __ ] oysters yeah that's a
good question I'm sure but next article
hey guys I hope you liked that episode
of just kidding music you did but okay
so this takes place in Ryba Stenmark and
it's a small Danish town along the
southwestern coastline of the
Scandinavian islands and it has huge
unwanted invasion of Pacific giant
oysters that um they're saying that have
been invading since 2010 and they are
seriously threatened mean and vicious
how do I stirs invade that's what I'm
saying just like grow a year at a time
but another inch like they're not even
addressed creatures maybe they add like
parasites or they take up the whatever
like they do ruin the ecosystem that
that environment has well yeah they're
saying that they are threatening the
living conditions for a lot of animals
and plants in that area which is one of
their most important natural resources
well then what they need is call the
natural predator of the oyster that area
don't stuff is a [ __ ] up the Chinese's
of that fill predator whoa do they have
a lot so bro ah that's a two-month
supply out in the 66 you guys like it
cooked or raw
both
[Laughter]
never had these Chinese steamed oysters
with a steamed with black bean sauce and
ginger oh I know I have it I had it with
the ginger the scallion and the soy
sauce that's good too but there's one
with the black bean sauce whoever had
that we should get oysters after this
good now yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] down the way they steamed
it there's like this little pop and as
soon as you break into the tell ahjussi
oh man I don't like you want people
overcook boisterous which is like I just
don't do that which is most the time
yeah sometimes I just rather have a
rather you know didn't overcook it don't
do it
so Tabasco a little lime in there hmm
yeah so the Danish Embassy to to China
posted an article on this Weibo account
about this and so they're saying that um
that after Chinese decisions read this
article with the problems they had like
over 5,000 comments saying like send us
over hitting me yes that solution yeah
that's a different information they
don't want though that it because you're
just going to replace [ __ ] oyster
with bag of [ __ ] and piss everywhere
from trash not let's not do that
yes I'm going to recently comments so
when one says Denmark and invents and
eater visa for Chinese visitors offering
unlimited vehicles unlimited entry
within 10 years for save of up to a
month each visit the oysters will be
extinct within five years and another
person commented five years five months
is enough is true
you want the oyster to be extinct or
just endangered lettuce and no welcome
pack them and sell them dude what if you
pack them and you give it to like the
third world countries whatever even have
food would not have a food supply the
cheap voices all the time you know what
I feel like actually like Chinese people
are less picky than homeless people how
do you like a us how much not thinking
of like just like the Americans that
were surrounded with and I feel like if
tooth was homeless and she has an 8 for
5 days and someone gave her ownership
like oh oh maybe now is just endless or
something else that's weird i duck tea
or something yeah any right to the
duck's feet but Chinese people that are
well fed bill it is they're probably eat
food off the floor
from a Chinese person throw that away
[ __ ] pig feed bed come on we're all
the waiters Bentley with a picky dus
mouth issues Oh God
oh man the Danish Embassy in China so
they will forward all of these creative
solutions to the relevant people put it
in a box ice it and then ship it out
yeah
easy yeah there was even a Chinese
company saying like you know what we can
just import the oysters over here don't
eat them like crazy that they're
poisonous delete oh well they are saying
that they the water in Denmark is really
clean and I have a really clean
environment so most of the oysters
should be delicious but they're saying
like first consult with the local before
you eat any of them though just to be
safe
yeah because they're called like in an
invasion does that mean view poises
originally from somewhere else or or is
it an overpopulation yeah that means
like Bart said the Predators see the
[ __ ] is step up the game
put some otters over then they'll [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up ya lazy ass otters wake up
oh I like let me eat on their thumb
exactly wait you know you know raccoons
eat oysters and crabs not to like
hey everything here is being clean trash
I want a raccoon be really cute though
how did I get the crab they have I do
know because cracking is open in honor
wash things they wash everything before
the et like James like always daddy's
the [ __ ] yes I guess I'm thinking of
like the crazy claws and stuff I do look
at a raccoon eating 24/7 yeah just like
that they don't even look at what
they're grabbing reminds me of someone I
know
you just have to you have to you could
have pretended we have committed me
around locals would better than actual
examples I'm Tanika
I think case you could take down half
that population yeah I'm self I don't
did you grow a lot less usually why he
loved it so much I saw only eat seafood
why realize I didn't like beef I
actually I only started grew up like
that like so now I there's a few things
like Bridget I didn't like my mom used
to make this dish called calm calm calm
tongue was a bone marrow soup everybody
[ __ ] loves I shaded it well is it too
much like beef they don't like you every
[ __ ] in the winter my mom would make a
fat part of my mom would say the same
thing you don't know how lucky you are
people pay a lot of money for this in
Korea I like mom I can't eat it it makes
me throw up she goes eat it or I'll kill
you
I eat it I yak on the tables next year
it's not little the reintroduction of
beef to was done for me by having it
cooked medium rare versus having it
well-done
I hated the stringiness I hated the
taste of well ground beef and the only
time I like beef was when I had it in
hamburgers you know I relate to you a
lot because it allows a kid eating like
I'd miss out on so it was always so
stringy and my jaw always get tired and
like talk eating baby so much work like
I don't like it and then not until I met
you guys you showed me the way to
medium-rare and I'm like I remember the
first time you had it you had diarrhea
could you start was Aneesha my son was
cramping up like crazy and living like
some of you to is raw beef hmm but I
never looked back
I'm done I eat oysters I like it but
after a while when I started thinking
about it too much
the slimy like raw the slime enos and
just a mucus eat texture I'm just like
all chanting I've had enough you know
how to sign and grow up eating oysters I
think I would hate them or you grew up
eating them I grew up eating that my
daddy used to love like high schools
like Mexican - it's the way like
Mexicans prepare it and so every single
week we would go eat seafood or he would
make it at home and he loves casino one
so I was used to it he would teach me
how to prepare which is like the line
the salt like I put a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
on exist so Mexicans do we can't just
eat things just the way it is
so even our fruit dude with that chili
on that [ __ ] I could live my whole life
probably not even be support I can just
do seafood I can't even do that I need a
hot beef every day every day yeah if I
if I eat chicken for two meals and I
didn't eat beef fat yeah it's like a
[ __ ]
what about feeling a man yeah like where
the [ __ ] is a red meter they're so raw
me what like I I miss beef and my
husband what I haven't had it in a while
so like I can have probably a steak uh
once a week and that's really about it
because even when we went to Hawaii
I had the local moco that's about it and
I had like a steak dish once but it
wasn't that much but most of the time I
could just keep seafood pork would be a
little bit harder for me because I love
bacon
I [ __ ] love carnitas I love pork
belly I love all this [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] flavors everything and I love
spam so that would be hard but you got
scrimped Chilean sea bass salmon trout
squid delicious that stuff's like
cookies to me though Bucky like 20 of
them I think that's why I never get full
oh yeah if I get my eight fish I could
just breathe fish so I mean at least
like six fishes
you mean that high fat cottage gotta
stick right here's a big fat ribeye you
feel cleaner door because I feel like
when I eat like a lot like a queen [ __ ]
no I know I like when they have a lot of
me like a lot of red me or like a lot of
pork like the next statue like so greasy
and heavy but like when I eat a lot of
fish I'm Michael okay you know I'm Wyatt
you know that's true but I know I think
growing up I've been a little bit
scarred with seafood just because of the
type of fish my mom would cook [ __ ]
journals I understand no mercy this
river food time for food actually I'm
agreeing with you the competing your mom
well yeah I'm nothing you you a beaver
platypus issue this is really good dude
hey guys I hope you liked that episode
of just kidding music you did please
press the like button to show us how
much you love it and for more videos
click right up here
[Music]